you know what's so interesting about
me and you was like yeah you know I'm a
fan of yours I couldn't even I don't
really know what AI is
like other than like dildos or ar right
like
like you've had some Electronics in it
no I don't think a dildo classifies as a
robot because I thought that's how they
were going to take over [__] mankind
just well they start with these the
[__] womanizer that knows how to eat
a [__] and then they're like we don't
need men anymore but like it's so
interesting that I couldn't even like I
can barely tell you what my dad does for
a living he's a lawyer I could kind of
like he's called me and said hey man you
gotta stop talking about what I do
because you're not doing it right I go
what do you mean he's like that's not
whatever you're saying I do I don't do
and so like I couldn't even begin to
explain your job to my daughter
well I think there's the way you do the
job which is the way you experience life
the regimented just even just a
nine-to-five job right you don't do work
nine to five no but I work much more
than that yeah but there's no
every kind of lifestyle has its
complexities I think nine to five means
you have to wake up at a certain time
every day do people tell you to pull it
back and they're like hey you're working
too hard yeah a lot of people what I
want in my life what I love in my life
especially people close to me are the
ones that say work harder because
everybody how do you get them how do you
get them I don't have anyone there my
life that does that everybody's always
worried about me
everyone's worried about me everyone's
always worried about me the only thing
that no one ever says if I showed you my
DMs right now on my my tax all it is is
like hey man I'm worried about you yeah
like Joe I love Joe to death not once
has he he always I don't know if you've
seen the carrying Joe eyes where like
I'm worried about you where it's like
and you're like hey man don't do that
and he's like I'm worried about you and
you're like don't [__] worry about me
I'm working it's I'm just working I love
working I love what I do I love what I
do I can only imagine that you love what
you do as much as I love what I do
because that's all I ever want to think
about is all I ever want to talk about
it's all I ever want to be like I I I I
when my wife wants me to take uh August
and whatever the August whatever the
[__] September
no but like July and August off after we
do fully loaded and
I was like no
I was like what do you mean like so like
what I'll just what am I like sitting a
chair and stuff she's like no you can do
like take up a hobby I go writing jokes
can I get on stage can I do sets in the
city because I'm not gonna [__] you
do you want me to like like I don't
understand I don't understand people who
don't I don't understand people don't
have the drive to work
all the time I don't understand that I
envy it I envy it because I go I would
love to just be like I'm gonna play
video games I can't play a video game
if I did I'd be on Twitch trying to make
money like I love how do you find
someone who goes you need to work harder
yeah especially when they see like I I
don't know what you look like but I I
look tormented when I'm working very
hard like it means
like it's easy to worry for my
well-being it's not like I'm a
happy-go-lucky but I'm happy underneath
it am I working too hard is like on a
plane every other day or every day
getting up at six working out and then
going into like two in the morning or
one in the morning and then going to
sleep and then getting up at six working
out getting on a plane going to another
place
like that's what my working is just a
lot of travel in mind if I didn't drink
on planes I don't think anyone would
probably worry about me at all they'd be
like no you're doing great